[Musique]
c'est de la frappe c'est de la frappe je
suis sûr que tu as pu mener ça tu vas te
retrouver dans une constellation
accotements avec brad pitt qui arrive
dans une fusée
parce qu'entre espace de quatre pages
qu'on est jeune marseillaise
connaisseurs
messieurs bonjour je reconnaisse
nationale
c'est parce que vous croyez cette résine
ne m'appartient pas c'est hakim jimmy
vicaut chinois du tout monsieur c'est
pas vous voulez vérifier vérifier son
casier vérité lumière le mien il est
vierge le cias impute la tête des
marques c'est vrai j'ai raison pas
regarder ces dalles sont jeunes et fume
depuis l'âge de 4 ans regardait dans sa
chaussette il ya une grosse boulette 12
g qui vient d'acheter ya même pas
moi c'est toi s'ils ne sont pas ça lui
monsieur lui c'est quelqu'un c'est un
truand c'est quelqu'un de pas bien
hypocrite un hymne au crij de la chasse
allait pas le croire il est tunisien
tahar est d'abord ça dure
nom de père en fils de plus
s'il vous plaît messieurs mais sion se
calme je crois qu'il ya méprise arts
avait juste pour l'entier selphy avec
monsieur bougheraba qu'à faire un film
formidable la vie scolaire métier
extraordinaire dans votre rôle de prof
là c'est moi j'ai adoré bravo bravo pour
le rôle et vous avez aimé mes films ou
sinon c'est m'intéresse pas ce que tu
dis en fait quand je te vois quand je te
regarde je parlais de parler avec toi
regarde-toi regarde-toi par le moi ça
m'intéresse pas donc tu la fermes
maintenant tu as compris on pense les
filles on se lance à lens lens acquis
mais auparavant sur la photo carte et
vous téléporter vers sage et vivra plus
on a bien séché la
tonique aller à trois on dit produits
illicites un deux trois produits
[Musique]